je ne crois pas à la démocratie directe
je crois à une collaboration des élites
et du peuple en fait j'ai concept sûreté
extrêmement banale sur le sujet mais
quand même
pour essayer de réfléchir enfin je crois
qu'on est tous sensibles à un certain
état de un mélange de mécontentement et
de passivité
du corps des citoyens
c'est une sorte de paradoxe qu on a
parlé du cas des croyances collectives
de ce qui fait que de la nation et de
tout ce qu'on veut mais il ya quand même
quand même j'ai été débogueur à un petit
niveau et je veux dire aussi avoir une
représentation concrète et démographique
de ce quel citoyen c'était que une
philosophie politique qui s'applique à
un corps des citoyens dont l'âge médian
est de 25 à 30 ans c'est que c'est une
philosophie politique mais là on est
dans des démocraties où l'âge médian du
corps électoral est supérieure à 50 ans
et donc comment s'étonner de ce qui a
peu
de de nous au niveau d'un
d'accélération dans la prise de décision
et suivent
même si les règles comment dire si les
procédures sont les mêmes ou sont
améliorées sont parfaites on sera
toujours confronté
à des démocraties très mature où le
niveau de vie reste très élevé mais où
le pouvoir électoral est donné de plus
en plus à des gens qui ne travaillent
plus qui sont consommateurs sans être
producteur alors ouais je commence à
avoir des doutes sur le suffrage
universel
vraiment je me dis faut-il garder le
suffrage je suis je trouve que
maintenant le vieillissement du corps
électoral donne des arguments contre le
suffrage universel
d'en mettre dans mes moments de folie je
me dis on devrait supprimer le droit de
vote après 25 ans
[Musique]